はい それでは今日の話を始まります
よろしくお願いします
えっと 始末するところだから
講演の内容は全然始末はつけていないんです
で まあ一応一年間いろいろ話したものは省略して
大事なものをもう一度並べただけだと思います
で 賢者は正しく始末をつけるという
心も体も心もすっきり軽くなる捨て方の極意ということ
えーと まずは必要なものというタイトルで考えてみましょう
私たちに必要なものがたくさんあります
一部は手に入っても 必要なものはすべては手に入りません
ですから 必死で頑張るしかないんですね
一部は手に入り 入らないものに対しては結構頑張らないと手に入らないんですね
手に入ると喜びを感じ
できなくなった時は悔しさ
苦しみなどなどを感じるんですね
まあまあ 失望感からね
いろんな精神的にまあ落ち込んだりはしますね
手に入らない場合は 世間でいう成功とは欲しかったものが手に入ることです
この世間で成功 成功といった言葉ってよく使ってますね
その意味は その人が手に入りたかったものが手に入ることが成功なんです
随分シンプルな定義なんです
基本的には食べ物 服 住居
薬になります で 基本的にどうしても欠かせない必要なものは
仏教 その四つに分けているんです
それについては まああれやこれやとガチャガチャ言っていられる場合じゃないんです
食べ物は必要ですし 服も必要でしょうし
住居も必要でしょうし
薬も必要なんです 面白いことに
時々動物たちも服はないんだけど
薬とか使ったりはします
それが揃うと 知識 社会の中での位置
権力 楽しみ 喜びなども必要になってきます
そこで我々にこの基本的に必要な衣食住薬というものが揃ってくると
さらにいろんなものを必要になっちゃうので
いろいろ知識欲しがっちゃうんですね
いろんなものを知りたくなっちゃう
別に楽しみたいと それ以外楽しみたいということもなってくるし
で まあそれでは物足らなくて
ちょっとみんなの間で格を作ってリーダーになりたいとかね
支配権力になりたいという気持ちにもなります
この2種類が一緒に混ざっているからよくわからなくなっているんです
じゃあ私はそちらで言ったんだからといって
人間が明確にこの 2つ分けてないんです
ごちゃ混ぜなんです だから自分にあなたにとって何が必要かというと
もう何もわからないんですよ
ですから 何を必要ですかと問われると返事ができなくなるんです
皆さんも自分に聞いてみてください
私にとって必要なものは何でしょうか？と
そう簡単に答えられないでしょう
頭がごちゃ混ぜになっているんです
だから 最初に我々は必要なものは仏教は 2つに分けるんです
一つはもう欠かせないもの
不可欠なもの もう一つはその他ということになるんですね
あってもなくても大したことはないもの
そういうことで 人間にとってよく見られることは
この何が必要かとよくわからないんですね
人は必要なものを分類したり
カタログを作ったりしないんです
必要なものが無限にあるかどうかは決められないが
限りなくあるような気がするんですね
で 私たちは何か必要なものは何か限りなくあるんじゃないかなということがね
そう思っているんです
それを表現する面白い物語がありますね
いくつかありますね もう神様か幽霊か誰か来て
ある人にもあんたにこの希望が 3つ叶えてあげますよとかね
で そういうエピソード
どちらでも最終的には大失敗するんですね
もう何の希望かなってなくなっちゃうんですね
で やっぱり我々も同じシミュレーションしてみれば
自分にとってはね 神様が希望 3つなら叶ってあげるそうと思ったら
何を希望するのかと で
これ計画立てたらできるかもしれません
だけど やっぱりかなり苦労すると思います
結局は物語と同じく何も得られなくなっちゃって失敗する可能性もあります
だからといって人間に必要なものは無限にあるということは決まったものじゃないんですよ
これはちょっとした言葉だけで
人間の要求は無限にあるというのはちょっとした表現ですよ
ちゃんと事実を調べて言っていることではありません
しかし 個人個人から聞けばよくわからないということだけは確かなんですね
それは限りなく苦しんで頑張っ
頑張らなくてはならないという条件を作る
そこで我々にとっては限りない
よくわからない いろんなものが欲しいんですよ
どれぐらい欲しいかわからないんだから
我々はもう限りなく頑張らなくちゃいけないんですよ
もう休めないんですね
そういうことで この要求がカタログにしていないんだから
あのカタログというのは
皆様のよだれを垂らして読む
あの商売のあれじゃないんで
カタログっていうのは専門用語で
図書館の本はカタログにしているんです
これこれぐらいのあるんだよというね
その意味で理解してください
我々は我々の要求 必要なものはカタログしていないんだから
すっごい苦しむ羽目になるんです
それから決して 満たされないという精神的な不満が結果として現れるんです
だからたくさんなるんだから
満たせましたと もうよかったとは言えないんですよ
これで私は必要なものはすべて揃いましたと
そういうことは言えないんですよ
そういうことはいくら頑張っても
いくら頑張っても満たされてないんです
だから すっと生まれてから死ぬまで満たしてないという
その精神的な病で悩まなくちゃいけないということになっているんです
それで満たせないということが
衝動に生きる衝動になっていますね
足らないのだ 満たせ 満たしたいのだ
必要なのだという迫力で生きることになるんです
もう楽しく生きてるわけじゃない
なんか抑えられてるんですよ
脅されてるんですよ ですから
まあ必死で生きてるんです
誰でも で なんで必死で生きているのかというと
もう満たしたい 足らない
その暗い気持ちなんです
いろんな必要なものあるんだと
私の言葉に入れ替えると
これ貧乏精神なんですね
貧困精神なんですね ですから
人間一人一人が貧乏神なんですよ
自分だけじゃなくて 周りにも同じ
もうウイルスをばらまくんですよ
結局人間というのは貧乏神の精神で生きているんです
人生とは得る 取る 集める
儲ける 貯まる 収集する
まあただ言葉を並べただけで
で 獲得する 収穫することなんですね
人生っていうのはそんなもんですよ
じゃあ考えてみてください
我々 朝から晩までずっと何やっていますか？何か得る得る
取る取る 獲得する 収穫する
それが人生なんですね
皆同じことをしているので
奪い合いという現象が次に起こるんです
そこで我々人間がみんな獲得
獲得 収穫 取る 取る 取る
取るですから みんな取る取るんだから
取り合い 奪い合いになるんですよ
だから人間社会の生きるということは
奪い合い もうかなりやばいんです
もうあっという間に取られてしまうんですよ
ちょっとしたことで 生きることはそれで戦いに競争に変わってしまいます
すごい綺麗な順番でしょ
ちょっとした失敗 カタログ作ってないんです
それで結局 今現状状態でもう生きるということは競争
戦いなんですよ もう戦いの結果を言うまでも必要ないと思いますけど
もう負け組が出て 勝ち組が出て
もう勝ちと言ったってもどうったことない
自分が期待したものをね
必要だと思ったものが得ただけの話なんですよ
別に何に勝ったわけでもないんですけど
そういうことで 我々の生きる世界がもう成り立っています
ということで 人間というのは
この貧乏神の精神で生きていること
お互いすごく怖いこと
お互い奪い合ってますからね
ちょっと不注意になったら
微妙にちょっと不注意になっただけで取られますね
で 登る まあいわゆる上がる更新速度
これでテーマちょっと変わります
私たちは専心しているつもりですけど
本当は更新しているんです
これがいかにスピードを上げるのかということで必死なんです
更新速度を上げよう上げようと競争しなくてはいけないんですね
余裕がないんですね 人間に
暇がないんです 人生を喜べないんです
必要だと思って獲得得したものを使用する暇がないんです
そこであんまりにも必死で頑張っていろんなものはいるんだけど
これ使う暇がないんです
私もいろいろ品物を買って置いてありますけど
部屋にはね もう使う暇がないんですよ
もう 2  3年経っても開けてない
この CD とかね  DVD とか
もう 4年経ってもビニール袋ままでもありますし
開けたってもちょっと一回もう3分の1ぐらい見たら
もうもう後で見るぞと置いておくだけで
まあそういうことで 我々は色々ものを取っちゃいますけど
それを使って楽しもうということはできなくなっているんです
暇がなくて 得ることにものすごい忙しい
何のためにやみくもに苦労して獲得したのかわからなくなるケースは多いんです
結局 人生を振り返ってみると
何のために今まで生きてきたんですか？という疑問も出てくるんですね
それに構わず 競争という更新速度を上げてしまうんです
得るものは使用できるかないか
そんなこと関係なくて
必死で競争しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから これは人生が幸福へ行くべきという推定で喋るならば
これは更新なんですね
不幸へ進んでいるんです
幸福へ進んでいることが
本当は更新して専心しているはずなんです
誰も幸福へと専心しないんです
不幸へとかなり勢いで更新するんです
そういうのは世界見たらもう明確なことなんです
社会は発展しないんです
まあ変化あるだけで発展だと勘違いする
まあ更新ばっかりなんです
はい 愚か者の宝物 更新速度をさらに早めるために
人間が あの 何でしたっけ
これは 貨幣制度 モニタリングシステムというものを作ったんですね
だから得る世界でしょ
だからものをいろんなものを得るだけ
ちょっと困っちゃいますよと
得られなくなるんじゃないかと
損するんではないかという
この気持ちが働いて 貨幣制度を作っちゃったんですね
人類が これ大変なことなんです
あってはならないことなんで
人類にとっては 金を払って事件を終わりにするという意味で
債務再生はファイナンスになるそうですね
辞書から引用したんですけどね
まあ英語ではだいたいファイナンスシステム
ファイナンス ミニストリーファイナンスとかね
マネーという言葉はあまり使わない
モニタリングという言葉はあまり使わない
ファイナンスという単語ですね
使っているのは このファイナンスというなんか古いラテンもフランス語でね
なんか金で片付けるという意味だそうです
もう本当にその通りになってますからね
それで人は必要なものという概念も忘れて
金のために命を惜しまないという勇気を持って頑張っているんです
結構勇気があります 命は惜しまない
金のためなら どうなってるんですかね
自分に必要なものを得ようとした道が
もう金のために生きることになっているんです
それで金自慢するんです
それで金のせいでどれほど世界が苦しんでいるのかと
ですから 私はそれは愚か者の宝物だと
で 次のタイトルは悪魔を崇拝する
今 金が人を操っているんです
あるべきなのは この欲求
必要なもので操られることなんですよ
動物は未だにそうでしょ
餌で操られますね いろんな動物園で飼っている動物たちも
いろんな なんて言いますか
芸を見せたりするでしょ？すごい面白いことをやったりするんですね
で あれって餌 全部餌で操ってるんです
それが賢いんですよ どうせちょっと遊んであげたら
もうおいしく餌をくれるんだからね
苦労しなくても 動物の立場から考えれば
野生で餌を取るよりはもうくれるんだからね
持ってきて だからまあちょっと遊んであげたってもね
まあかなり収入が多いんですね
結構収入の方が多いんです
ちょっとの仕事で だから私は動物の生き方は賢いんだと思いますよ
どんな動物でも まあなんとか自分の方に顔を向いてほしいければ
もう餌でするしかないんです
人間はなんでするんですか？金でするんです
情けないんです 何でもやるんです
金なら 人の命より金が大事なのです
実際には金がないのに
架空的に金があるように数字だけの世界も作っています
今我々生きているのは金がないんで
それほど しかし数字だけこれ
コンピューターでデータで動いてるんです
単純な数字があっち行ったりこっち行ったり
それで証券株とかね あれって全部嘘なんですよ
単純なもうもう数字だけあっちこっち行ったりするだけで
株主がいるんですけど
株の株券 1枚見たことがないというのは事実です
で 証券株などに挑戦すると
1日にして貧困のどん底に落ちることもあります
ですから 自分に金があったと思ったのに
5,000 万もあったと思ったのに
もう首を振る間で全部なくなるとかね
だから初めからあったのかとも聞きたくなりますしね
で これ考えるとき頭にあったのは
このリーマン・ブラザーズという人々がやったけしからんなことなんですね
世界を道連れにして潰れるという
もう世界も金にすられる連中だから
まああんまり文句は言えませんよ
技術があっても 役に立つものを作れる生産能力があっても
金融が首を絞めているんです
だから私にいろんな品物を作れるんだ
人間に役に立つものを作れるんだという技術を持っていたっても生きていられません
首を絞められています
金融が だからもう生産の世界じゃないんですよ
生産する人々は奴隷なんですね
金という数字を握っている人々は神様で
そちらの勝手で生きていなくちゃいけないんです
だから そういう金の数字を持ってる人々は
もう見たこともないんで
自分がどんな会社持っているのかっていう
そういうもう世界で それは人間の幸福な世界なのかと
一人一人人間が幸福になる生き方なのかっていうことが問題です
だからこれ悪 ひどい目に遭うんだからね
これ悪魔崇拝なんですよ
悪魔崇拝と崇かったのは
もうやればやるほど不幸になる世界
例えば経済大国とか何とかとか言ったりはするんだけど
大国になればなるほど状態が危ない
病院に行く前に人が死ぬ
病院で受け付け受けないんです
なんか原始時代みたいですね
昔から女性が子供を産んだんですけど
一番シンプルなことなんですけど
それが日本でできないんです
業者が赤字を減らすといえば
第1は  人件費削減です
で 面白い すごいさ もうやります
やります しっかりと人を首を切るだけです
第2のプランはありません
私は面白い考えというのは
前も日本でね 経済不調なことがあったりして
もうものすごい残酷に人件費
人件費削減したんですよ
それで大きな工場いくつかもう火事になって
もう灰になっちゃったんです
石油やら化学工場とかね
もう全部ゼロ もう何もなくなっちゃったんです
儲かろうと思って人件費削減しちゃったんです
だから腕のある人々は追い出されたんです
何も仕事をできない 高い給料をもらう人々
私の会社 それだけ残ってバカみたいに待ってるんですけど
あのひとつ片っ端から調べて
ネジを締めて緩めて 温度を上げて下げてね
圧力を上げて下げする職人たちがなくなっちゃったんです
だから儲かったんですかと聞きたいんですけど
今もそういうことをね
やってますけどね まあトヨタも始めてもうかなり 1万人ぐらいでしたっけ
人を削減するとかね まあ実際仕事をする人々を追い出してどうするんですかね
それからなんでこんなにでっかい会社なのに赤字になるんですかね
だってソニーにしたっても
もうものすごいマンモス会社でしょうに
だからそちらのあの会社グループだからね
いろんな名前で あるわあるわ
もう世界的に見れば もうどれほどマンモス会社だけど
赤字ですね 屋台ラーメンやってる人もそんなに赤字にはなりませんだけど
まあ大した収入はないかもしれませんだけど
売ったラーメン分は一応金入ってますから
まあ一杯は本人にとっては
例えば 10万  20  10円
20円しか儲けなければね
10杯売ったっても大した金は入りませんだけど
自分のためには しかし
赤字と言えるんでしょうかね
その能力さえもないんじゃないんですかね
いらないものですから
買わないものですね 作るでしょうに
どんなマンモス会社であっても
作るものっていうのは本当はいらないものなんですよ
我々は作ったんだから買うんであって
別に欲しいと思っていたわけじゃないんです
だから欲しくもないんだけど
あまり売りさばいてるんだから買おうかなと思っちゃうと
こちらにはもう余分に金がないと
まあどうでもいいや そんなもういいや
買いましょうという感じでならないと
だから一般人がそんなに金の亡者で金あふれてるわけじゃないんですよ
みんなにちょっぴりちっぽけな給料しかくれないんだから
その人々は厳密に計算しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから 経営学者ではなくて
一般人がすごい経営のプロでなければ生きていられませんよ
日本の奥さん方でもね
かなり経営のプロなんですよ
しっかりやりとりやってますから
だから野村やらね もうそういう巨大もう三菱東京銀行とかね
まあそういう会社にいる人々より頭がいいんです
そんな赤字になりませんよ
赤字になりかかってくると
なんとかしてもうしっかりと削減するものを削減してやってます
だからって明日から食い物はないや
それはないんですよ ちゃんと食べさせてるんです
よく知ってますよ どこを削減すればよろしいかと
だから仏教的に言うならばね
まあ世界は女性が支配するならば
こういうことは起こらないんです
必要なものであっても
自分が儲けることだけ考えて値段つけるんですよ
だから 人に必要なものを売る場合は人が買いますよ
その時買う気にならない
余計に高いんですね ものすごい余計に高い
例えばもう何でしたっけ？もうニンニク一つ買いたいと思ったら 450円やと
バカだったら買うんだけれど
いや ニンニクないことにも使わないことにするぞということになっちゃうんですよ
しかし 必要なものは必要でしょうに
だからそこを 450円にしているのは
この作り側の儲けを考えているんですね
損したくないんだと だから私の言葉で言うと
あんた方勝手に金に無駄遣いするんだからでいて
こちらの責任にするな
ようと 作るために 100円もかからない品物なんですけど
店で出す場合は これはもう 3,000円ですよ
マイクロソフトのソフトウェアと同じですよ
何人か集めて 頭の悪いグループが集めて
なんとかプログラム作って
それでガッタガッタで
それの値段は それで世界人類みんな買わなくちゃあかんでしょうに
それだったらね マイクロソフトのビスタやらなんだら
そんなのは 2,000円で 2,000円で売れば
私は一番適当だと思いますよ
2,000円  3,000円で
それでもボロ儲けすると思いますよ
なんだこれはと 自分たち好き勝手に金無駄遣いしたい
だからあなた方は払いなさいということだから
赤字になって倒産するんです
生産費は消費者の責任でしょうか
金が絶対権力者なんですね
なんでそうなるかというと
会社にしたっても金借りてやってますからね
金が権力者なんです だからちゃんと返さなくちゃいけないんですね
それ返さなかったらもう大変なことになるんです
人間に大事なものを作る会社ではないか
だからちょっと優しくしましょう
それはないんです 薬を作る会社でも
金借りて作る やっているならば
ちゃんと払わないと もうそれで終わりということになっちゃうんです
だから金がやっぱり神様になっているんですね
だからもう作る側にしても
適当な値段はつけられなくなっちゃうんです
そうなってくると 買う人々は買う気にならないんですね
それで作っても売れないことになります
それでお金も借りているし
品物も売れないし で 結局倒産することになっちゃうんです
赤ちゃんのミルクにメラメラミンが入っても構わないんで
現代時代では なんで粉ミルクにメラミンが入ったかというと
このミルクの構成をチェックするんですよ
そうするとメラミンが入ったら
たんぱく質の濃度が高くて数字が出るんです
機械で 野菜に禁止している農薬が残留してもそれは構いません
使用 ただ冗談でいくつかの例を出しただけで
使用期限が切れたものでも
加工食品にすれば人はわからないんだからね
だから構いません 使用禁止の米でも転売すればわからなくなりますからね
あとで人の口に入ったっても知ったものじゃないと
そういうことで 人間は味が鈍感だから
もうどこで作ったうなぎでも
国産のどこかの地方の名前を入れればよろしいしね
まあ牛肉でも まあもうみんなもう偉そうな高い牛肉資格と高山牛と言ったっても
最低のものを食べたっても味がわからないんだからね
だからラベルだけ張り替えれば大丈夫です
だからそういうことはしょっちゅう世の中で起きたりして
それバレちゃうとまた倒産に陥ったりして
誰のせいですかね それは
無責任 無責任で実体のない証券を売買することで
一時的に儲かったので
世界は丸ごと金融危機に陥っても構わないんです
何人かやったことですよ
この世界に 今の金融危機は
皆金に操られているのです
金という悪魔に憑依されているのです
一人一人が何をやっているのかとわかっていないんです
金が命より大事ですということになっています
どこまで崩れるんですか？最初の必要なものから命は始まるでしょうね
もう命は関係なくなっちゃったんです
どここともなく もう金という悪魔が登場して
みんなを憑依してみんなを苦しめているんです
それで悪魔はやっぱり返済でしたっけ？返済しなきゃダメですから
どこで見るんですね 今
金とは実体のない数字なので
その数字が激しく回らなくてはならないという考えがあるんです
これ 誰でも知っていることで
金っていうのはずっと動かないと経済状況悪いんだと
だから皆様の貯金はものすごく狙われてるんですよ
あれ 貯金動かしませんだからね
預金とかいろいろありますからね
銀行では扱っても扱わなくて
隠しておいたりとかね
そういうのはもう動かないんですけど
政府は数知ってます どれぐらい金が人のところで止まっているのかと
これ何とかして使いたいんですね
自分の金使いたくないんです
で 理由は金回れば会社が儲かるんだと
皆様方は明日さっさと外へ出て
トヨタ車を注文すればもう大丈夫です
と トヨタ会社が助かります
で  3台目も 2台目も車注文すればね
そうすると一時喜んじゃったりして
もうもうもう結構売れたんだとか
次にまた皆様に文句を言うんですよ 3
台だからこれぐらい税金払いなさいとかね
で 駐車代 これはもうもう
なんていうまさかインシュアランスでしたっけ？あれやこれやとか
あらゆる方法で次にさらにいじめるんです
だから助けてあげてもそれでやられるんです
消費者が だからいつでも断言的に犯人は消費者であるということです
買わないんだから有罪ですね
買ったら買ったことで有罪です
例えばゴミの問題 皆様作ったんですか？ゴミは
発泡スチロールとかビニールとか
ちょっと 3円の価値のあるお茶とかコーヒーとか
これ 110円の缶で飲むでしょ
それでそれから時間はもう 1分以内でゴミになるでしょ
これ皆様の責任だそうです
なので皆様方 必死でもうパレード行って抗議したでしょうね
もう飲み物は缶 缶にしてくださいとか
ペットボトルにしてくださいとか
余計なことを向こう考えて売り出したりして
それからゴミを減らしなさいと一般人に言う
買いたくもない電気製品
あれこれやと強引に買わせて
もうもうもう電気をもう減らすの減らしてくださいと
あなた方はもう二酸化炭素をもう温暖
なんて言いますか この温室効果ガスはいっぱい出してるんだと
まあ簡単に言えば呼吸するなかで法律で決めればね
いるか否かは関係なく
金があるか否かは関係なく
消費を拡大すれば解決だと思っているんですね
それもまた金のためです
なんで消費拡大しようかとしなさいと言うので
金が入ってほしいんですね
消費拡大すると自然破壊する
そんなことは後で考えますと
それも消費者の問題にしますからね
で 消費者はその罠に引っかかっているのは
すべての消費者も金が命より大事だと思っているからなんです
喜んで落ちる奈落 より珍しい最先端の技術などのうたい文句で品物を宣伝する
無知な人が誘惑される
いるかいないかわからないが
買いまくる そのうち食べれば食べるほど痩せる美食を開発すると思いますよ
新しい もうもう最先端
先端の技術を駆使して
もう最先端の医学をね
遺伝子のもうあれこれやって
もうもう世界一美味しい食べ物作りましたと
それは食べれば食べるほどやせるぞと言っちゃうと
どれほど買うんですかね
みんな だからそこをその余計な例えを出したのは
いかに宣伝は嘘かっていうことを教えたかったんです
あの ある飲み物があって
あの コマーシャル文句はあの血圧を気になる方へ
あれってどういう意味ですかね
血圧を気になる方への飲み物ですね
よくそういうコピー作るんだから
だから法律ではもう捕まりませんよ
血圧下がるって言ってないんだからね
買わなくては困る 売れなくては困る
金が回らなくては困る世界です
もう生きることもどうでもいいんです
品物を買わなくては 品物を売らなくては
金がずっと回っておかなくてはという
何のためにこの金というものが現れたのかと
同じものを微妙にバージョンを変えて 3ヶ月ごとに売るんです
同じ品物なんですけど
まだ使えるのに古いものを捨てて新しいものを買う羽目になる
私たちも乗ってますからね
バージョンを変えるたびに新しいものを買ったりする
しかし 溜まる品物は処分できない
捨てて自然破壊すると
それは消費者の責任だそうですね
で 作る側が地球のことを考えるという看板を出すだけ
今最近よく流行っていて
いろんな会社がね なんだらなんだら会社が地球のことを考えているんだと
考えなさいよと 勝手にこちらに言うなよと私は言いたいんですよ
新幹線に乗るといろんな看板読みますけどね
みんな見事に地球のことを考えているんです
いかに人を馬鹿にしようと思っているのかというと
おそらくそういう宣伝を出すと
もしかするともう政府もそういうことで宣伝しているんだから
もしかすると税金も下がったりとかね
あるいはコマーシャル料が安くなったり
何かあるとあると思いますよ
で コマーシャル料金安くなるならば
地球をだんだらカンダラ会社が地球のことを考えていると
何々会社と自分の宣伝ですからね
地球のことを考えるのでも
地球から消えた方がね
早いんですけど そうやって我々は喜んで奈落に落ちているんですよ
落とされたわけじゃないんです
自分で飛んだんです それで我々はこの砂の上でお城を作っています
それで必死になって これ安定させようと頑張っているんですね
IT までが発達して 安定した世界を築いたと思っている
しかし 世界の電力が 1週間止まったらね
たちまち原始人になってしまう発展なんです
発展はしていますけど
もう例えば 1週間電気がなくなったらどうしますか？そんなのわかりませんよ
この太陽とかね いろいろ宇宙の宇宙線がありますから
磁場が変わっちゃうとどうなるんですかね
1週間ぐらい 太陽がね
特別にフレアを作ったりしちゃうとわからない
爆発していますから あれも
それで地球がこのなんとか電気
自分なんて磁力で覆っちゃうと
もう電気が動かなくなるという
まあそれ私の妄想かもしれませんだけど
私はただ妄想したって面白いことを妄想しますからね
笑えるものは で それは皆様違うところなんです
で そうなると 1週間でみんな原始人で火を立てませんだからね
それって発展ですか？と
ほんのわずかな変動でホームレスになる安定ですね
我々生きている世界っていうのは
ほんのわずかな変動が起こると
次から次へとホームレスの人々が現れちゃうんです
もうバリバリ仕事をした人々なんですよ
それから仕事をする気もあるし
できるし ちょっとの変動でもそうなってしまうんですね
だから私は現代の砂漠
社会っていうのは まあ砂の上に建ったお城ではないかなと
砂で作ったお城 はい これで次の説教に進みます